who
is going to use this crisis the most and
who will this crisis help the most does
this help Biden does this help Trump
does this help DeSantis does this help a
candidate from the outside that's going
to come in who does it help or it's too
early to tell what do you think
Tom I'll go to you first uh I think this
helps DeSantis for three reasons the
mainstream media once again Trump
derangement syndrome they're out there
attacking him saying it's all his fault
and it's irrefutably on Biden's watch
and so the guy that's standing over here
that there's really nothing stuck to him
is
the guy just got a benefit out of a
couple big crisises and rock throwing
and so I think that helps DeSantis I
think uh not that he's running I don't
think Bernie Sanders is running but this
entire storyline just screams the the
Millionaires and the billionaires get
all the favors out of here and the
little guy that the whole Main Street
versus Wall Street narrative right there
I mean this is Silicon Valley Bank
getting bailed out I mean in the heart
of tech Valley out there and this is
just is going to go right to the squad
and AOC and they don't care about you
they don't care about Main Street all
they care about is Wall Street Silicon
Valley and it's just gonna be the same
old you know Bernie narrative and by the
way that's that was the infancy of the
Occupy Wall Street movement how this all
started and he's kind of not wrong uh to
call out this sort of crony capitalism I
don't know I I think that
um
I think that because this can affect
people who are on a salary that are
getting paid I think it's a little bit
of a different thing and because
you do have pain from people who made
the investments in the bank the the the
big the big money who were the investors
the stockholders they got wiped out you
know the bondholders probably get a lot
of pain that they're going to feel so I
I don't think that that's the way that
it'll be told in certain media Outlets I
don't think they'll tell the whole story
I think they'll do exactly what you're
saying I think you're right that that's
the spin that they'll try to put on it
but this is not a Donald Trump problem
he did not create this you know this was
a Dodd-Frank issue and this was a lack
of oversight issue which is for the last
couple of years under the current
Administration I mean they the the
balance sheet of this Bank turned last
year this was a very profitable Bank
these Investments turned based upon what
the FED did under this administration's
watch so I know they're going to try and
spin it the best that they can but
anybody who can see through that can see
that this is clearly
on it's clearly on the FED it's clearly
on the additional stimulus that caused
the inflation it's and it's it's on the
lack of oversight on what these Banks
were able to do at the end of the day
isn't it on specifically Silicon Valley
Bank more than anything right
they were allowed yes it is of course
but they were allowed to not have to
disclose these as tier one Capital
losses because of the Dodd-Frank ruling
uh Rob just pulled the sub run the
sentence blames woe culture for Silicon
Valley Bank collapse reminds him of
financial crisis
and
um Bernie Madoff he's trying to jump on
top and jump on it the only reason I'm
laughing is because Rhonda Sanders is
going to blame everything on world
culture that's his entire ammo this Bank
they're so concerned with the DEA and
politics and all kinds of stuff I think
that they really diverted from uh
focusing on their core Mission uh uh
while noting that he didn't have any
similar information on certain Florida
Banks or any concerns on Runs run on
banks in the state by the way can you
pull up what uh the chief uh uh I don't
know if it's the Chief Operating Officer
but one of the c-suites uh or could have
been the VP what the lady said in her
profile you have it I send it to it's a
picture that you have it's one of the
three pictures that they're right there
go back this is the head of Financial
Risk Management and model risk Silicon
Valley Bank UK limited the phrase you
can be what you can't see resonates with
me as a queer person of color and a
first generation immigrant from a
working class background there were not
many role models for me to see growing
up up I feel privileged to co-chair the
lgbtq
I don't even know ERG and help spread
awareness of livid queer experiences
partnered with charitable organizations
and above all create a sense of
community for our community employees
and allies this is the head of Financial
Risk Management
and Moder risk Silicon Valley Bank UK
Limited I mean what that profile has to
do with how good you are at your job I
don't know
but listen go for it hey I think
valuetainment is going to rock because
I'm half a Syrian half Armenian born and
raised in Iran lived at a refugee camp
in Germany and I can relate to people
whose fathers is a 99 Cent Store cashier
and parents gotta do I can't imagine if
I put that on my profile and now you're
also a married man who's straight and
you have kids and you like coaching
baseball and what does that have to do
well to her that could work against me
to her that could work again don't
assume that it's a her because her name
his name is Jay oh my God
our guy posted a picture on pbd podcast
the other day if you go to Twitter
profile he's so funny the stuff he posts
uh uh uh he posted he says uh only kids
from 90s will remember this I don't know
if you saw this or not Rob this meme
even made me crack up I almost peed my
pants when I saw this I'm like this
guy's funny I'll send it to you here
okay go two more lower it should come up
right there two more lower uh right
there only 90s kids will remember this
yeah I remember that yeah well it's
crazy I was I was uh I was having lunch
yesterday with a buddy Oliver if you're
watching this and he said that he was
traveling
and there was a drop down box just like
this and he had to enter his pronoun had
to he was traveling and it was I was
like what'd you put in he's like well I
put in you know he is he's like I don't
I've never done this in my life but it
was all the he she we they us who what
when when they
lgtqg and he's like dude I'm just trying
to get a flight here but honestly if you
think about it to some people it's
intimidating that the American alphabet
has how many letters in its 20 say six
yeah and that's already intimidating
yeah I know right now you're throwing
pluses and decimals and Pi signs holy
Only the Strong will survive with
that many acronyms I was in the military
we had to remember acronyms but this one
makes it even tougher so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]